[Musique]
laissez-vous Pascal Boniface bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
directeur fondateur de l'Institut des
relations internationales et
stratégiques
lyrics une première question au-delà de
ces annonces de Joe Biden qu'on vient
d'entendre de nouvelles livraisons
d'armes plus d'argent aussi en soutien
aux Ukrainiens qu'est-ce qu'on va
retenir c'est l'image forcément le chef
de la Maison Blanche en visite à Kiev en
temps de guerre ça c'est cette inédit
depuis le début du conflit
oui c'est une idée du conflit ça
rappelle un peu les images d'Obama et
George se rendant en Irak en Afghanistan
dans des contextes bien sûr
d'oppositions différentes parce que là
les stabilité directement en guerre là
ils ne sont qu'en soutient et je
conviendra bien sûr ce sont ces images
de
ski papotant et se promenant
tranquillement de soleil dans les rues
de quai donc pour donner une image à la
fois de maîtrise de la situation et de
solidarité il n'est pas si fréquent que
le président est dans un pays en guerre
et donc c'est vraiment l'infirmation à
la fois d'un leadership américain sur la
coalition occidentale qui soutient
l'Ukraine et en même temps de cette
solidarité le message il est bien sûr
envoyé à l'Ukraine mais également à la
Russie et le message envoyé à la Russie
ne comptez pas sur notre lassitude ne
comptez pas sur une éventuelle fatigue
américaine ou occidentale dans l'aide
accordée à l'Ukraine voilà un signal
fort adressé aux Russes ce sont les mots
du chef de la diplomatie
ukrainienne juste après cette étape
américaine volody Mear zelienski qui a
même estimé de son côté que les Russes
n'avait aucune chance de remporter cette
guerre on est quatre jours avant cette
cette anniversaire un lien dans du coup
d'envoi de l'offensive russe où en
est-on aujourd'hui Joe Biden pendant la
conférence de presse a rappelé ce qui
s'était dit il y a un an entre lui et
volody merzelinski qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour pour vous aider ce que vous
pouvez faire c'est de venir le monde
occidental pour m'aider à vaincre les
rues c'est ce qu'il a réussi Joe Biden
est-ce que l'Occident est suffisamment
uni pour pour arriver au bout de ce
conflit
qu'on ne voit pas le bout de ce conflit
pour le moment et la demande de selenki
des il y a un an c'était j'ai pas besoin
d'un taxi j'ai besoin d'armes ça demande
est toujours la même jusqu'ici Biden a
refusé de livrer les avions qui
réclables ski et il n'a pas disons de
profiter de cette visite pour annoncer
un changement majeur mais on voit bien
qu'il y a une amplification de l'aide
occidentale générale pour dire un peu
face à Poutine on sait que vous
mobilisez on sait que vous préparez une
offensive majeure mais nous serons là
même si les livraisons de chars de
combat qui ont été annoncés ne seront
pas effectives dans le court terme mais
c'est bien donc pour montrer qu'il y
aura une aide et après il y a peut-être
une divergence entre certains
occidentaux puisque je pense que Biden
comme Macron Macron qui a dit hier je
souhaite la défaite de la Russie mais je
veux pas l'écraser bagden s'il veut pas
livrer d'avion c'est qu'il ne va pas
être pris dans un engrenage qui
l'entraînerait dans un
conflit direct avec la Russie et en fait
cet engrenage qui lui serait plutôt
auprès à l'accepter parce que cela
renforcerait bien sûr sa main dans la
guerre que lui-même la Russie alors où
les Américains mettent en garde la
tension les les Chinois vont livrer des
armes heureuses que Pékin a formellement
démenti ce matin on a quand même le
sentiment malgré tout qu'un an après les
lignes bougent
les lignes restent un peu les mêmes
néanmoins c'est-à-dire que vous avez à
la fois un monde occidental qui est très
uni envers l'Ukraine un Sud qui ne l'est
pas et à la conférence de Munich
l'ancien président colombien a dit que
cette guerre n'était pas la guerre des
pays du Sud qu'ils en souffraient donc
on a toujours cette division entre
l'Occident et le reste du monde et la
Chine est pour le moment toujours dans
une situation où elle aide indirectement
à la Russie mais elle ne va pas l'aider
militairement est-ce que ce pas sera
franchi est-ce que par rapport à l'aide
occidentale il y aura une aide chinoise
pour le moment les Chinois n'ont pas
franchi cette ligne là qu'est-ce qui va
compter Pascal Boniface dans les
semaines les mois qui vont qui vont
suivre on a entendu évidemment ces
propos qui sont une posture pour
volonymère Zelinski qui est de dire que
les Russes vont perdre bientôt perdre
cette guerre on sait que c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué au vu de ce qui se passe
et de ce qui nous est rapporté sur le
terrain notamment le Dombas on était
tout à l'heure avec avec nos équipes
actuellement déployées dans l'est de
l'Ukraine les Russes sont prêts à une
guerre d'usure on y est un an après les
Ukrainiens commencent à montrer des
signes de fatigue
bah oui mais tout le monde est un peu
fatigué les Russes subissent des pertes
importantes et au bout d'un certain
temps quand même cela ne pourra pas
provoquer les réactions dans l'opinion
russe celle-ci est passive elle n'est
pas informée mais si le nombre de morts
est même inférieur à ce qu'annonce les
Américains 200 000 morts ça peut
peut-être paraître beaucoup mais même
s'il est que la moitié de cela c'est
énorme et il y a quand même beaucoup de
frères de père de Marie qui ne
reviennent pas et donc ça peut peser
aussi à force même si pour Poutine ce
n'est pas très gênant ça peut être
gênant pour la société civile russe et
donc le problème c'est que beaucoup
d'annonces d'envoi d'armes occidentales
mais qu'elles ne sont pas encore là et
que pour le pour l'instant la Russie a
le nombre pour elle et l'Ukraine a bien
sûr le soutien industriel ou militaire
des Occidentaux mais l'ensemble des
armes annoncées ne sont pas encore dans
l'équipement de l'armée ukrainienne
merci beaucoup Pascal Boniface